[Musique]
ce sont des journalistes qu'on ne voit
pas sur nos écrans et pourtant leur
image reste imprégnée dans nos esprits
pour la première fois le caméraman
patrice massenet raconte avec ces mots
les coulisses de ce tournage
le journaliste paul tout en or a réussi
l'exploit de le faire parler sans filtre
c'est lui qui venait mme sue tirer les
vers du nez et réussissait bien là où
j'étais pas capables ils allaient
fouiller pis ça sortait quand j'étais
émerveillé quand il criait parce que ce
qu'il écrivait c'était ce que je pense
c'était une vie exceptionnelle que j'ai
eues j'étais au bon moment au bon
endroit et le bon moment pour un
caméraman c'est souvent lorsqu'il est
explosif en 1992 ce sont les guerres de
clans somalie où une famine sévit un
tournage périlleux qui lui vaut le titre
du livre j'ai risqué ma vie pour des
images
moi je filmais et de la voiture et il y
en a qui m'ont veut filmer
il n'était pas content et quand on est
ressortis du palais nous attendait il y
avait une mitrailleuse sur une jeep avec
des baltes l'étape par l'ong comme ça
deux genres de choses ratiez rien qu'ils
étaient prêts nous tirer dessus ils
étaient tous tombent sur l'étape alors
les terres comme ça dit m
et j'y suis horriblement peur ça c'est
un voyage extrêmement difficile de
l'anarchie totale
le journaliste raymond st-pierre s'en
souvient ils veulent que leur vie à nos
côtés ce ça crée des liens qu'on ne peut
pas oublier qu'ils sont toujours là
toute notre vie c'est plus fort que
l'amitié cc c'est vraiment d'avoir
d'avoir vomi sa vie en jeu pour faire ce
métier là plus de la voir faire ensemble
c'est une solidarité incroyable un lien
indéfectible lie les deux hommes
on les entend jamais les cameramans ou
très très rarement etc des journalistes
comme nous d'une façon qui doivent
s'adresser à l'association eau secours
trouvent autant que nous leur travail se
de parler avec l'image les émotions sur
place j'en ai c'est sûr qu'il y en a
toujours eu mais c'est la plupart du
temps c'est après que ça se passe c'est
derrière la caméra c'est comme si je me
cachais c'est comme si on voyait un
tunnel toutes ces habitations sont
maintenant désert madeleine poulin jean
françois lépine patrice massenet tourne
avec les plus grands et remporte
plusieurs prix
témoin privilégié de l'histoire il voit
se dérouler sous sa lentille les grands
bouleversements en amérique du sud en
afrique au moyen orient en europe et
deux ans avant la chute du mur de berlin
il est le seul caméraman a filmé pendant
deux mois le mur de 155 km ce qui lui
vaut d'être fiché par la stasi la police
secrète d'allemagne de l'est jean duprat
au moins belles photos de nos peuples au
zaïre peu de temps après le génocide au
rwanda toute l'équipe de radio canada
est attaqué en pleine nuit alors qu'ils
se rendaient à leur hôtel
combien de fois je me suis dit pourquoi
j'ai accepté d'aller mais il ya une
telle satisfaction retour au temps j'ai
eu peur autant jeter contente de le
faire après on me donnait une réputation
d'être un casse cou mais c'est pas vrai
j'ai toujours été ce que j'appelle un
risque calculé un risque calculé qu'il y
aura sans doute sauvé la vie et qui lui
permet de raconter aujourd'hui ses
mémoires un livre dédié à ces finira
pour expliquer aussi ses longues
absences
il faisait beau de l'eger guise radio
canada montréal